for two speakers were going to speak
about the same subject of your sleep the
title of my talk it means to be long
second-generation immigrants in transit
identity their reasons I think we were
they speaking together tonight that it
worked together from this project course
you years it published an article
together and so
also present together elemental isn't
that super quick they're two different
people so we have here tonight all
joining escalate do it we received our
PhD in history from Johns boo in Paris
in 2008 with a dissertation entitled in
England immigration culture and estates
the cultural dimension of our
immigration policy 1958
one told me that already had a very
distinguished career she's being amazing
hello
Chicago she also being a promoter shadow
at the National Institute for
demographic studies and 15s when I
visited Democratic in Paris and she is
currently a postdoctoral fellow at some
school in Paris worst of civil
partnership researcher and also teaching
degree of integration work and into the
intersection of immigration culture and
politics in Europe insurance and in
North America had been published in
several major journals shashlik aviso an
article with with Patrick in 2009
entitled boho consulted a diversity of
the legality into anything worse than a
doctor again no visibility she also
published the move more and into our
political Patrick Seymour who is our
second speaker tonight the chronology is
going to be the first
unique the presentations Patrick Simone
is a director of research at aneta the
SCT nationality democratic we're in 1000
and he's also a research fellow at the
Center for European studies at South
school and I said that today trance is
one of the most important forces in the
field of international migrations
manganese and patterns of inclusion and
exclusion in France and Europe yes
approach is very important studies as a
scholar of nutrition through a series of
groundbreaking groundbreaking studies
that have combined very rigorous
statistical analysis with upset deep and
insightful historical and from your
perspective so there is work is really
contract
the mastery of technical dimensions and
also emotional physical dimensions the
leaders of this groundbreaking studies
in the city no touching to up and in
origin on katella diversity depositors
your thoughts which was published in
2010 and which is believe it or not the
first encompassing sociological studies
of the impact of origin on social
studies trans other books and there many
of them
for all that include ability monument to
the national commercials in Europe and
something that you do to me the baby
indigenous to easier to this I would
like two or I could at the time of the
content articles actually
articles published in a scholarly
journals on immigration discrimination
and diversity about the list of all the
job
very long so I won't even try to call
the article but innovation community
learn French quality culture say give a
free quote for sensitive solution for
SEO
another device is
earning like that international drugs
and so on and so forth e-ticket also be
a very important voice to the ongoing
debate in France on the use of ethnic
statistics I would say it's been the
once again a very important culinary
voice but also someone who has been
intervening in the public arena by
publishing community in major newspapers
and I no speak about this tonight with
obviously put speak about this during
the discussion and Easter i would say
we're going to add it
in full bright fellow and is Russell
Sage Foundation to New York City so
we're very lucky to Happy New York as I
said at the beginning Oh Shaheen and the
attic and work together only on the
European project and product development
project a migration and diversity in
Europe which is abusive the basis for
the talk tonight we are very happy two
of them
the middle contest tonight that was a
representatives of a new generation of
colors concerns cars people who are
providing us with rigorous 12 in a
moment of very very important debates in
transit in Europe over immigration and
diversity and people were making us
stronger that
and your brain can presentation jalen
nice that we give the paper together
it's a John paper and is already
stretching decides to split between two
and I will be just want to speak enough
under to take too much time together to
leave the same crowd that would be
written
but nothing on this project and present
that to today's invitation is open 7
yunchan Piero being there tonight a nice
place to give this paper which is work
in progress without first in time hero
that we lose on this paper so there are
not only seven eighths of the claim for
your illusions to kind of representation
we do it's a lot so as you see
belongings national identity in French
which is these days very hot debate in
the advanced only they are being a
disaster which as we
good for the environment whether it's
every three days somehow with a new
statement new decoration by Ministry of
Interior
what is being French or what is the
position of the place situation of the
minions in pressure setting so it's only
need to be able to date but everything
that has been said and I won't touch on
this date in the news and as you see
first we will go through very brief
background information on national
identity in France because it's useful
to understand finding that we have and
the two other parts will analysis of
this survey that we imagine that is the
trajectory of religions so they wish as
to two-dimensional one Giza quantity
quantitative survey 24 22 thousand
immigrants signal generation and what
those who call the mainstream population
so it's constantly survey and the single
part is qualitative survey with
interviews different topics on a section
of response of the multivariate which
will be analyzing the second part by the
Englishman interviews the public
narratives of maintenance so the idea is
to go with the quantitative data about
what does it mean to be French it is
very schematic information we get
gathered through quantitative so they
are single part would be more in-depth
understanding how to the response behind
opposite of niceness emulation I society
the first have to give my soul's all
souls and we do also our access
beginnings
as well and we got this sensitive
information from the US on us about the
situation France that was written in
2005 during the riots going on France
and Andy's recipients when present says
the real problem the failure of the
white and christian friends to view the
darker muslim compras Phillips has when
citizens community defect has been the
creation of a generation of young males
like in Brussels control and then
quipped to secure gold job even though
they can break through the formidable
trials of prejudice faced by guna wraps
and you guys but we will not sit down
here us holiday as food sources about my
situation and we try to see how this
complex of discrimination and
rationalization as an impact on the way
immigrants in circles
fine or the season set as French in the
French to say the first to go on the
background
but you may know that French citizenship
is combining two different dimension
which is a very often completed in one
which is a civic political dimension of
citizenship butts in one room or two or
more stoic which is perceived to be less
important
the context of France compared to other
countries in borrow and pheasants to the
casual dimension to of that meta
description is really the crucial
dimension is not a very important
dimension for
fractions and we will see that it's
maybe not as political as its claim to
be and the quote for now they lemme see
recreational or Frenchness every level
special society is maybe not exactly
what is procuring quite as procure in
the late 19th century
is now securing these things actually
friends but still the French model
integration have been conceived and has
been developed to try to create
structure to
to create unity through poverty in Maine
any openings very contrasting in the
american way of conceiving immigration
and the creation of the nation is that
in england's very different when they
come of course the new society the
social integration we try to reduce the
specificity is virtual social studies so
that after generations of the second
generation they will simply disappear
disappear with one dimension which is
deposition of fraction so they become
french as a city a seemingly disappeared
by simply complaining
the difference virtual specifically do
that in their participation on society
so friend with a Frenchman of
integration to understand the creation
of the French citizen that the
contradiction between being a fancy
being adding reference to an ethnic
background so that's that the I would
say the normative modern-day question
which has not really ever really worth
this way it has been recreated this way
to understand where public expression of
diversity of differences are perceived
to be in contradiction with a real way
too busy and it has been quite a crucial
during one century to produce
invisibility after one generation one
very important tool which is written
here we the statement that is six track
from the highland set of integration in
1991 which i'd like to share the idea of
the modern figuration what they even try
to define the main dimensional is
Frenchman or configuration say that is
not assimilation it's not corporations
in between rights and duties and what
differences could be tolerated but not
unfazed so it's a sort of a bill way
every time which is complicating to find
them since we your way and what is
important said that the French
citizenship should be the Parliament of
the process of integration so the idea
is that it is an odd way of the process
of deterioration not the beginning of it
but we can this definition of national
identity goes up because full time it
has been reported on immigration that
this was free tickets that mean that the
quality innovation of him melton century
is again the probate three decades and
will not block or the different lights
tons of these debates but recently what
the main idea that there may be some
contradiction between the norms and
values of the mainstream population of
those who are put forward by limits and
signification so one of the failure of
integration is visibility of these
immigrants in second generation on that
incapacity
perceived by the mainstream condition to
reach level of the dorms in value that i
spected promises so the disconnection
between the forward citizenship from the
political participation and the crucial
expectation
it's many at stake in this debate
International one World were the
relation of citizenship which is a bit
complicated to grasp so that's been set
at the end of 19th century and from
nineteen eighteen nineteen eighty 189
until today with a short introduction in
1993 until nineteen ninety-eight the
reserve sort of a virtual view soil
which is every children of immigrant
been born in France is French between
French and we really become French at
edge
so at this this is is in fact forums
which receive the citizenship of his
father or mother and then it will be
automatically French when cottage except
issues response being specific
its request to two across it before
otherwise they are all almost if a
person then French when you come on page
so it's a sort of a combination of her
useless and two significant difference
and for those who are not one friends
incidents say anything sense that they
invade reference attention by applying
into that mutation so it's a
discretionary decision by the state
except if you department to a French
citizens in this case it's a different
pattern but the metallization is based
on the assessment of a summation which
is performed by the state agent which is
deciding if the applicants is really
reaching the pretoria
requirement for being French unknown
there are not so many rejection of
applications only today for sex which
may be a very long one when it comes to
applicants we arrive at the job or
mineral that's because realty and we
need chains on this is damaged anyway
this is a similar way to the
consecration third way which is a very
complicated history is how much Fran
citizenship as being humble Nickelodeon
please so it's a very long story very
complicated one depending on the status
of this territories are we not getting
into that except to say a brief
statement that they are being stratified
which doubles a lot different
universities and she even in Nigeria
which pulls French Department in which
citizenship was was renting to the
Indians people with a different meaning
of
she can't even see that was granted to
the audience in the same department so
this history of citizenship in the
converter to its may have again
long-lasting consequences on the
perception of this country today and
specifically in our kids when we want to
identify the signal generation
of immigrants the biggest complicated to
make distinction between those who are
those who parents are born in Australia
and are well the dissonance of the
former
lasers or French inhabitants of Algeria
and those who are the descendants of the
potpourri digi news single signal range
transition from China which I've been
after the independence ranting the other
citizenship have become lions at this
time so it's very complicated to
reconstruct this distinction between the
second generation have to go very quick
with that so just metal alchemist lab
big a deal is about fragile entities a
census form 90 94 1 i'm sure you cannot
read anything about that so this is the
last one test ever even not change in a
most one century that's the same
question the question is you see the
third question what is your nationality
we got three different answers your
branch reverse crunch x position or your
forum and these categories our one that
I use very few people to categorize the
French population based on
attention the very tricky thing is that
being born French is not totally
understood and this issue go back to the
legal diffusion of being both French
signal generation backgrounds from a
foreigner farm shreena fund itself or
set as as a transport citizen is the
french valley position which is
automatically granted but still it is an
acquisition most of the signal
generation minerals to defendants that
has platform so it seemed that they are
realizing that perception as being
French videos and I make a distinction
for this bill to what dimension of the
village which is the recommend one to
concern this is another form for the
eternity to adjust to menu that
practices in Maine on territory was not
same one then the power you see the
categories we can be with that but that
amplification of the senses
nineteen thirty-one and you see clearly
36c clearly that the galleries which is
many competitors are between your
parents and teens to break up their
values and national he was reused inside
the group of the audience which artists
thing is that the distinction was made
between France and French okay so these
two curves give you the rate of
immigration which is bloomer and should
be this with the left the right bar here
so from beginning of the nineteenth the
20th century in here and integration as
as gross 100-percent to almost any suit
which is a stadium another that be and
from the ANOVA humans blue client gives
you the right of agua crunch so I
acquisition okay so you see that the
share of French citizen among the
immigrants is moving from computing % at
the hidden century through almost 40%
today which is really low oxygen content
of us usually about a third of the
immigrants are on urbans take a great
point in time maybe not recently the new
research integration process pilot for a
country which defines that with a very
open very boundaries definitions didn't
ship them the expectation that the
immigrants who should be French so it's
possible and so now let's get to the
findings from the yard so the Soviet was
talking about which has been made by the
Nancy together so large team which were
only two who doesn't nice more
opportunity to be possession
patient survey I'm going very quickly on
the description you don't need that
22,000 in this pond selling between
dating 260 more than them out between 8
and 15 years old so that's it work at
that we use and we have say five
different samples immigrants signal
generations and mainstream population
and we have a subsample of the office
the people coming from the offices
department well GTG parking is
complicated too dependent on see lyrics
which is a totally acceptable but
they're not really about an extra
probation as well so we are trying to
work using data or no to them adam from
or encounter so what does it tell us
about diversity you see these are very
early the right side which is 70 normal
seventy-six percent of the populations
about the matron provisions or what we
would call diversity in France today
it's from four percent of the population
which is not very far if you take the
u.s. from the red book on the share of
the first-generation Americans and
signal to measure very very comparable
situation I don't describe all the
guidebooks category you can do with this
kind of information Nowitzki from the
composition of the migrants on second
generation soft about 2.7 millions of
immigrants aged 18 to 50 years old and
almost 3.1 million on second generation
and when you see the country where they
come from or the country of the Browns
the second generation what are the main
groups are the Maghreb ians actually
horrible Tunisia for the 13
the same for the single generation etc
these vanish and Italians make a very
much signal generation are very small
share of England's due to these three
affiliation and so you would find say
about half of the simulation
would be from librarian for society
freedom diagram and the other will be
from European language okay well when we
say immigrants without some somehow
completely two different time of you on
those game as adults that's the idea
that we have and those are quite young
with that balance and then it will be a
very close situation than those who are
a second so let's call them generation
15 which isn't very original body usual
term used to categorize those who are
born abroad k in very running the child
rights okay and you see that most forty
percent of the immigrants chemical the
age of sixteen which means they are
power their school
transcendental that socialization of
friends so that love I'm not really
immigrants as we usually think about it
which in it which is a rupture saying
about the second generation we can think
about the distinction between those who
do have to leave it impossible of anyone
in even grounds they are French current
and you see that almost fifty percent of
the second generation do have a French
part so again create some differences
and you see the Malaysian of this with
the ethnic background you will find high
level of big city for the European
second generation on the lower density
for the evidence of the due to the time
span as well illumination so let's go
very quickly on being French so this is
the description of the citizenship and
either three four categories when I
French bios branch by position which is
this garrison middle and an information
button towards isn't which is very less
we wrote a bit which is a brain
night mention and then those who do not
add frightening and you see the interest
isn't she can make a higher up for the
signal generation almost a third of them
we define themselves as tools in society
in the French citizenship and the
citizenship of that part so it makes
what I said sizeable group and focus for
the immigrants have seen almost thirty
percent of them are French and seventy
percent are not French even if you
played by the kind of repetition for the
generation 125 you are a lower number of
Iranians on high
french jews by they came quite alone
easily the naturalization easily
and the others and you see the share of
the foreigners for several generations
pretty slow in five percent of the
signal generation do not have a fancy
dinner so when you say those who are
born inferences they are really
automatically French recommend age so
most of them ranking factors remain
French so that's at the general idea and
and what you see that when we ask are
you French Bibles of Transportation you
see that almost eighty five percent say
that there are providers don't say that
our vegetation they don't perceive
themselves quite parties so there is a
major discrepancy between the legal
definition of citizenship at the
individual position what he did so then
second question you ask a second
question do you think French great
straightforward question which is where
the appeal told me not well we totally
in French or you don't in French or
torrington don't you French a lot of the
question the same was asked about the
brains inertia p well for one of the
problems for the same generation
recurring for any ethnic fillings and
any information that well as you would
expect the immigrants do not feel French
as much at the mainstream population but
still two sizable group 50 push me to
say that the French but which is part I
even you should take those who do not
have the French citizenship it's the
foreigner government here put two
percent of the non French minutes to
define themselves as French which means
but they fit they need you to the be
considered even if they don't get the
national unity 207 sprites of web which
is a very important dimension I guess
and if you take the rotation to what the
or personal one of their foremost again
you have a very high mark so you would
find so combination it's possible to
eating french getting the sins and to be
a gentleman and ninety percent as well
so there is a sort of a combination of
the two rather than a conflict or
contradiction between two so there is
not an exclusivity of one citizenship
over again the other it's a more sort of
syncretism which is created for
eyefinity identity which is created by
this question and what is very striking
in that those who are decry the French
citizenship the immigrants do refer to
proceedings have still persistence and a
very much from their former foreign
student why we always keep this one we
should be complicating just say one day
that if you bros this feeling French
feeling frame with a very specific
country
ethnic background Reggie Ruthie that
first there is not use variation across
group so it's a share position and
suddenly it's the mint versions also for
the same dimension so there is a
decrease of feeling ethnic for the
second generation and go to the first
one that's basically the baseline of
this one this is even more complicated
to get very quickly to say and if you
combine the information but you see that
this is this yellow canary see which be
the affinity delta T and we see that the
single generation is increasingly choose
and I think an oddity to define
themselves about the first generation
and it is the main damage so that is
chosen by the schools so we are really
facing the inversions of the cylinder of
eternity but this is the personal
definition of themselves so how do are
they to see by the others we don't have
question about a specific third party
how do you see this question but we are
a sort of reference in question
do you think the other see us French
that was one question do you feel the
others but who is that in there the
question was people see me as a French
person and they were asked to answer
totally not a little shape with a
pregnant and yeah that we see that the
sizable more just take subside matter to
most of its bad person bridals do not
think that the other see them as French
and you see the variation to be quite
red and you see that European cruise to
deceive more thing that they are su
French more than elders and specifically
the second generation which is always
possible in this case so it seemed that
it's not related to the weather to see
themselves for with it where the other
person there so they construction of
Frenchness but the mainstream population
is not really based on here it's not
really balanced attention is based on
some nice
when space so that's the same category
but this time I take only those who do
you find themselves right and you see
that we see the usual suspect matter
against the people coming from the
overseas department and those who are
neutral subside and african and south
east asian not to see that they are seen
as French as much a table rather than
the motive is under Spanish and any web
reference position and if you try to
register the information what you see
that somehow we are gluing always sunny
ethnic racial categories in this case
and if you work groups we are very close
you get the blacks which are in
sub-saharan Africa and the US Department
will you address those feelings and get
Americans a general American tourism and
you see and the agents and the Europeans
that would be Spanish Italian bodies and
the other Europeans together and you see
that in some striking feature that
nothing to see that French when you
define yourself as French through a
similar
all these three groups who are somehow
physically in to press you say so it's
in that freshness is not built on the
everyday babies is based on how you look
like trans person so it's another is a
an invisible new pieces diffusion
process crunchiness which is tied to
more rational equation so we are moving
from belonging to recognition the King's
you but naturally that is not how people
perform the french national I poppy oh
the mainstream population is able to
devise scholar definitional stop
freshness how is it possible to
understand consider that black or wraps
up our French population and the others
are strange and sin that there is a
dissonance between the expectation
three practices even though they are
high-level meeting identities and even
though there is public school saying
that the problem is not coming from
other mainstream society bit more from
the difference on the second generation
wanna and we go to start the narratives
young diffuse okay well thank you very
much for this transition to that the
positive part of the desert so we in the
spot I'm going to
who will be moving into more details and
give you more idea of what it means that
what we're talking about when they say
that they don't feel French so we
contacted 26 in-depth interview we have
16 men and 10
age from 18 to 50 so that the
he was going to be
population also very important all this
population interviewed French they're
all over 18yo and during my presentation
I were referring to them with their
first name first name that is modified
will give you the gender age and also in
this order the novelty of their father
and natural tea of that mother
so in in this in this right i will show
you this what we define where some
competing narratives of freshness that
we think are interacting among
second-generation immigrants and that's
a way to belong to national identity and
this is also we are also going to try to
understand our process of authoring up
and not thinking that you do not look
friends in the restive population
operate at the individual level but
first I would like to erase a
methodological point that we were trying
to test himself with the survey which is
that so i think was touching upon this
issue all the bill in his presentation
to ensure that when you want to
identify a second-generation can be
raised in France you're confronted to
all those questions of how do you know
that that person is born from foreign
parents entity that's what define
second-generation immigrants when they
declare well my my parents were born in
Italy that's pretty simple but when they
declare on my parents were born in
Algeria now how do you make a difference
between a person will tell you my
parents were born in Nigeria highly
differentiated french expatriates were
born in Nigeria from a drain regreso in
the survey the census we have a question
about the national tea at birth office
people so the person say oh my my father
was born in Nigeria they may conclude
that his father was
and expected what is referred to in
mathematics at the quinoa however as
fetching explaining the complex feature
of the coordinate system I made that I
giant people actually we're also born as
rare French nationals when they were
born so some interviewing my answer my
father was born in French but that
person sadler might be lost mother among
the French Muslim at the time so how to
differentiate their sons of I genuine
events or not well we had another
question which was when Jerry became
independent when that country and the
corner rule became dependent did your
parents keep their French nationality in
which case you differentiate between
people who are born out of french
expatriates or that way
from people from universe bad even at
that point is not even here that people
are we gonna be able to differentiate he
went from
section 8 is basically first because
what was possible for some important
subjects to actually keep french
national small number did it and but
more importantly is that and that's
something that we test with interviews
is that what people have a very low
understanding of exactly what was that
staying on what was their nationality of
that parents out there but they might
have an idea of is the national interior
their parents all right now because that
has to do with the answer actually men
are on a daily basis but other than that
we observe that they are very low on
level of transmission of the history of
parents why they arriving friends why
they might be and also a very
transmission of what it was to be living
in the colonial countries and also on
the part of the inspector repatriates
they didn't necessarily know of its
difference of stairs that are so
complicated so basically with this white
edge of interviews we were trying to
test it people who answered my parents
stay French when it became
they were shooting events on the
leadership and talk perpetuates so we're
also testing that and for that reason an
important implication for the original
devil
said that we also have in this
interviews some people who are French
people born offend people so members of
what we refer to as a majority
population so that also gave us some
interesting insight of how they succeed
Frenchness preparing to the other group
the second generation immigrants book
that we looked at
so all of our interviewee and as I was
mentioning I also name of the majority
are they very important feeling of
belonging to and the way they described
it was that it was belonging to the
location where they leave and their ways
asleep they mentioned ways of leaving
office there were even other options
these questions house also we're also
asking them that more question paper
that more a question of the place where
you want but they emphasized more the
idea that they share ways of living and
I think this can be observed by the
veterans of the world here in their
answer so edition of my son said well ID
fear so automatically I have to have
better nationality semin said I think
French I studied here I want to live
here
and I said that I was born here I went
to the same school at the other marks or
illness I feel French that feeling of
being French is also mirrored by the way
they define their feeling when they go
abroad and that many quotes that refer
to the experience of being back in the
back being of visiting the country of
their parents origin and so obviously
one reason why they would feel foreign
in that country's language aspect so
general would say in rock revival French
simply from your linguistic point of you
referring to the fact that what has an
accent in his big rally when he can haz
be ready at all but then there are those
who go a little bit deeper and say well
in Algeria items match you have another
culture
another way to dress the way to think to
reflect on things why interestingly
relation to that interview that also
that makes the case it's important to do
quite a cheap survey that I'd beginning
to savour when I go to attend what I'm
not sent any more imagine to refer to
the fact she use a giant passport who
she called devil nationality but they
let you on which is talking about how it
is really to be there then she had the
exact same statement would be very same
in agile I am French so I think it also
show the importance to also get going to
when that introduce people to understand
how this time identity she's are
articulated as what I do who is from
very tiny single experience it said well
when I was in Senegal Michael told me
people would see just the way you walk
they will know that you come from
friends so I didn't give URL yeah
of what they think make them differently
make them French on a selection of
bacteria but also in attendance systems
on this idea that they have ways of
being and I think this way to feel
French when they're in the country of
their parents mirror the way they think
of richness but they are in front so
even if that belonging to their parents
country of origin that sometimes they
hold double nationality that work
Benedict and have several other imagined
community might be concrete and strong
that identity is not competing identity
with destiny nothing matches something
that so
so it's important the result that we
the kinetic data is that this multiple
identity are they insane person and it's
not because if you an attachment to the
country of their browser gee that makes
not the French
however I get a little bit more figures
for you akiza you are missing that with
this so we're going back to the
quintessential numbers here and what
what we can see that's all if you stop
by the more the first question when they
were often ask are you often asked about
your origins we see that if you look at
immigrants thief we remove that mask
black so I'm referring to
faucets area and
department there is a very stable trait
they are they're asked about their
origin should they be immigrants
generation 115 generation Jews second
and generation to 15 from expects so
when it comes to the question of origin
if you're black person that comes very
often it's table when it comes to the
aging population is interesting it's the
Green Line it drops but then increase
again so this idea that even though you
are after a few generations this
question is to ask you for my great
units also a same thing and basically of
the blue line the last line he also the
Europeans at first when they right there
are asked by the proteins that go the
children and variants but as hinted
drops so when it comes to generation 1.5
and then I generation to it since I'm
like we were saying new pins are
pressing depressing for French and then
I'll ask
and then the other questions was do
people perceive you as French and here
again you see the poo now in the
Europeans it drops after one generation
they think that Percy does French
whereas if you look at last my
brilliance they they start with both
50-person and they stay generation going
through there above forty percent so
it's still very consistently results and
shows that in a way they're Frenchness
is denied to them so we're going to try
to see what they mean by this what
sentences are then to them so we try to
experience to explore a few solutions or
some cubes for this automated process of
other in gratis profanity that we need
your pension so
first well behaving as French doesn't
seem to be enough because freshness and
also about how you look so we have some
athletes in here saying big French is to
integrate accusing friends you have to
integrate it you have to do everything
as 10 people do so so integrating the
door discordant said however he goes on
I am NOT a bad person I have a burr my
face is that photographers so we have an
indication gear of the when you look his
face that eating identifying us era and
that's not much worse and the enemy who
is with feathered so definitely seen
story too because his father is running
his mother's French it's fun at dinner
Billy of Road map quiz reference to
Cambodia didn't return to top the
language to him or giving
need to keep to Cambodia but he says
well for mia has the same culture event
throughout his friends before them they
think I have a different culture so if
that's how people see you then you came
tonight it is young asian and so on
paper parts of Asia that
the related to benjamin is very small
it's just it'sit's father and his
brother Mariota to prevent very early
but in his interaction with the rest of
the society that Asian identity is
you're stronger and that comes from his
interaction with and contact with other
people
and then what makes you visible then to
it can be different to the rest of the
population well here we grouped some of
the important issue that we thought were
coming out and use our first is
insisting on physical features so it
would say well my complexion is very
dark so people can tell by the way I'm
afraid cygnett project this whole
expedition say well sometimes when one
has international tease nada depends on
your friends also as I do who saw
earlier the one who keep Aquitaine with
french fries awaits talking in the
market you say well a first person who
is not questioned whether he or she is
French is a French person who is white
and has a French name
he doesn't say that he was said he was a
friend but that's what his ideas of what
he heard anything is spread among the
people he interacts with let's go
physical features we also have an
important animal Chris religion systema
acid well I radiate something that is
not French something that is messy and
interesting in that part of the
interview I was doing interview and so
we come about this question of freshness
and she she told to me about when she
enacted see before that she's she's veil
which is outside there wasn't you doing
her in your living room and I'm human
myself she wasn't moving development
when he started talking about how you
French the rest of people she mentioned
the fact that true very well
that's what she means by i rated
something that is our friend and she
saved me the theater was like French
good she also articulated this idea that
if you do come a statement we got a
French Canada two different story
because he doesn't think it's a
practicing it's not a good friend is
really just is that ready just for you
he said well it's my surname I'm seeing
more at the message and he was sort of
protecting this kiss he doesn't think
entity that if you don't you let those
were the features that are they express
we're also yeah interestingly this sort
of standards of fitness how does a
french / salute x10 improvement so
general said I'm not a bro and I and
such people and say coach with another
friend groups and father's mother so
also that importance of what people the
interaction with the rest of the
population the important and when we
enforce of the earth I think reasoning
and also the question of this connection
is an important element in the identity
of serving you know
development is here but we had several
questions on that and yeah wouldn't that
be a friends are being discriminated
also reinforced that feeling so we had
you on fire I single mother Spanish safe
while you feel French until you ask for
your paper so you're being asked when
we're at a moment where it's it can be
very discriminatory he was walking with
friends there where whites and you would
young one glass as paper because during
the day in dr. Paris so that's how you
created
breakfast items to control also quite
typical of the expense of discrimination
to is also done player has a similar
most persons whose fathers Beninese and
mother's French that I think people see
me as a person of color but i'm very
discreet I'm not moving make trouble and
as a contract number of that test a
final exam we interviewed also check
whiny and serese patterns weather was
born French in a former French colony so
his father a menstruating community and
here we have an example of someone who
did not expand discrimination and for
this reason feel much more is too much
create some foreign origins and so we
say well people do not know that happens
if I will tell them
I like to mention that i have bright
averages it's a way to set myself apart
from people where to focus on being
vegetative the way for me to say but i
have a second wait for what
cultures I think it's very different
meaning of ethnicity in French context
Allah gives interesting contract at home
of the the other con disposable p so in
conclusion we have this competing
narrative the fringe net that are
articulated by second generation in
events that are in response to our the
society and rain 4dr brains of
discrimination but we also think that
the fact that the absence of that
presentation of diversity in a national
narrative and this racial constitutional
Frenchness they are also further
supported by the constitution of the
national narrative dizam little
inclusive of france poland equation
class and also ask them if they identify
with french restream masters and
that this animatronic be part of the
history of France is presented also
contain important role explaining this
competing narrative officials that are
interacting among this second generation
even looking for lots of questions I
have to start with a person that if
women are
me
top freshman that's a question that I
have had to face myself is work
also worked on raising hands another
poachers when he said he is to say race
matters as does my friend friend we knew
it and from work and perspective
that's something that I had to encounter
i presented my
what you know like we knew that you know
French are so what is what you bring
that with a Christmas and what you bring
to the good conversation so many know a
method in question is what does it
matter that even though franchisee
decide that is so that the very much
versus what was the effect of you know
the denial of praise
and
you know realize I can help people were
thinking they were living together so
that this kind of work does matter okay
I'm sorry this is a question so what
yeah I mean you know thanks so much to
the session but a deep conversation
alive
think about so I've done black American
session about conversation and honey
about the race and ethnicity and I sort
of always start frying for games with
this beacon of racial tolerance in the
middle history of african-americans win
friends and being accepting a Grayson
and so I have known that and then sort
of st. first ten that Ewing a lot of
arrows on bikes or second generation and
acceptor who don't feel functional you
talked about this bracelet opportunity
type center so this is incredibly this
confirms what I what I knew before so
anecdotally what makes me even more sad
i dunno i'm particularly because i am
very proud to be American you know I
love fried some trifle public I'm very
proud to be American I don't see it as
competing I is so I guess so that's
that's for comment that I guess the
question I guess so pretty basket you
said so yeah we saw with putting your
thoughts what is the future of society
and confusion is like it's not this
assumed as it seemed positive and very
nice on pessimist in
so more on the wet question before we do
more specifics
yeah warranty so I mineral had a more
integrated policy you know he's also the
ages young age I have a question for
clarification thanks first so if i
understood you correctly your basic
argument is another
be frenched but then proceed friends
because of
what you said is what I also saw it
would be stronger survey nearly all the
reports about
young French people
who say
I don't like France and so so perhaps
you can clarify head equation was good
that so too many questions right crazy
small things
I also like to hear about your
explanation in fact that people were so
discriminate against deathless want to
feel feel so entrenched because it is
variously visual effects people are all
intuited benevolence are proudly French
and eaten for Isis Amy's research
endeavors and whatever might be infected
with what is when they say they are
French or when they say they home in
fact the precious metals we offer
at this issue are never that easy joke
as in / semesters in national it was far
more like so see faith or locally or
additional morning doesn't say it really
sacred Obama's national identity or /
righted itself really white that's true
French and how this process of national
identity but more baby indeed as you say
location
work it doesn't know the same special
identity yes you your point right away
to about race could there will be other
factors at play for instance religion
also
that's a computational to to the
presentation to audiences hmmm ok so
somebody to be three opinion we go to
the so what question
well well of course you may say that its
sales price comes as no surprise that
there is one in France you could be
blabbin swing your bubbly race between x
1 which is wider than race and it's not
surprised that plays a role in fine
but still I think one of the sequence of
the i would say national meet the french
national needs that it is not explaining
that you could be very easily and
quietly combining ethnicity from
practices and low for being affinity is
not perceive as as so oh
identity new to this fear so there was a
salad completed in Vegas which is if you
define yourself as Franchitti's against
irritate you saved by family all weekend
of reference input on the history of
plans Felicity that be built as well he
needs to be sure to enter in France and
one of the consequences is that it's
still very escalations perspective which
is a requirement to just be detached
from these theaters nothing it's still I
play today with people debate national
debate on national entity is simply
saying that which is YouTube visible due
to visibly not French it's not based on
the practices of references you can
don't agree bit on
is made somehow take this direction but
it's more general than that it is the
principle of integration is seems to be
efficient so far that they think that
they were sort of a closeness between
groups that are supposed to integrity
and in this course is based on culture
which is a big one it's not a matter of
culture it's a matter of being invisible
and this time the new moon signal
generation is not visible to do the
forum generation from the parish the
Italian Spanish has been a man like the
installation voting is is today even
though but it is a smiley exactly the
same tile and even repeat after their
tails at several of time no matter how
do you give yourself is with some cues
that prefer that you not really power
this representation of friends as well
define it why to say I mean openly is
something else but it's not simply as a
contrast I would say the fact that is a
suicide uprooting the Romanians and the
Caribbeans I want to see
and the others even those problems are
branchville for than 10 generation it's
simply signal that there is an increased
the book presentation of Frenchness
which is not tied to the gods Vishnu
society something else so at least it's
not clear that it is perceived in the
price of it not sure about that and I'm
over that joke about the opposite which
is well wait a bit the generation going
to be replaced by a third generation of
men there will be periods we have less
screen nation they will get into a
french press ago and they will becoming
disabled that the others are invisible
somehow it's not the case because there
won't be invisible so if we have to
transcend the freshmen of integration
has to change because the statement has
does not fit with the situation I think
so that that's that's the somehow so
what formed which is to be able to give
two features one years it's not an issue
and i am not sure whether about the
question you asked by the fact that they
will refuse to be friends because the
artist
you get the note they don't tell it
exactly the consequence of defining
themselves French as a reaction against
discrimination there is not a direct I
to identity against pensioners that
would say welcome baggage not that it's
not that I thought that like this maybe
there was a strong and somehow it's for
this reason with crash monopoly of
integrations very bored with that it
creates trend dynamic towards
incorporation of the franchiser it works
what variables work so far I mean the
part of the heroes of civilizations down
the power receiving society is not done
so it's a betrayal you play the game but
the game is number one you think it has
to be play so this is discontent cloud
is account and then
yeah i was gonna answer the question
about tuesday they feel french so yeah
just to clarify they feel friends that's
what i was showing it at the beginning
they they get saying I feel French
because of this with that so we try to
you know give some content of what it is
if your friends that's what I was
explaining when they say we are you here
I sitting here and so on and so very
importantly it's not that they don't
feel French that they they feel that a
French person is not the person who
looks like them also in the situation
situation of the interviewer that we
were an interesting in at least in one
situation one interviewee opposed
himself to me that if you if you talking
to me if you apply they will take
intervene but they will not take
so they clearly improved to divide in
between wife and you know like like the
beginning here x 10 so and also i think
i think a long frustrating that i
haven't seen some interviews frustration
of being out do you feel French they do
not like this question I was now in long
interview with a woman who didn't
anytime I was trying to head sensational
Frenchness brilliant was to the question
if I was asking her if she she felt
bench that was not the question I was
asking i was asking you what it is for
you to be French and later on into you
guys so much said well it's always like
that cause people are origin and then I
said no no in my simple i have people
who are after not origin so you really
ask them a question is that yeah ask the
question oh look at NSA because the
question that I asked is what it is
going to be French and so then I can
so yeah that's attention about what
about asking second-generation nuclear
French I think related to the way on the
right is represented in the media
definitely the idea that they were
presented as disloyal to prevent
identity all the fact that is made about
the fact that did they support soccer
team that are from their impacts country
of origin but that's not something that
we say Macbeth that forgot topic we
brought it but that's part of the the
fact that they to feel strongly right
attached to their the country of their
parents but has not you do nothing to do
with the fact that they feel French so
yeah I think we have important points
and to make that that was very odd
consistent in interview that they
thought mentions more that it was in
dxperience the eyes of the other that
that were sending and just to answer the
quiz about religion at this point
well first there would be an argument
that would say that religion important
context may be in the boss communal
contestar be also specialized so that
could be
taking part to that sense dynamic but
yeah we try to a different unit so yeah
I think it's two viable that can play
something sometimes interacting people
are black and Muslim sometimes
associated em and it's different
experiences that was definitely what we
cannot conclude on that racial divide
divide and coastal coraline but
the religious aspect story of the woman
was Dale that picture is also very
important feature which is I had
something on the version on one
statement what needs to be done by the
region we have an equation but I don't
images which we asked for people to
generate four-dimensional Berlin giving
a list along by gender age sexual
orientation
region movies but remonstrations am
region and i was really striking fiber
condition has not ended by a lot of
people it was not mentioned so even by
people who define themselves as catholic
or leslie is not the way we define
having to choose
it's a team is it's a it's not perceive
us as a clear identity market and its
contrasting with the debate which say
that both slams everywhere and debated
use and I assume muscle people are as we
have seen in some of the quotes and we
have seen that being perceived as
bursting as a consequence the social
life so it's in that there was a good
insane between the way you perceive
yourself that you will find yourself
within you to stone and whether society
is reading in a domestic and I wanted to
make a sense of a ravine tennis time
without different findings that is the
self perception is missing we increase
so far and bathe it's creating the
personality has a very silent identity
so maybe we have done it in 2008 tools
already there but not maybe as much of
it is yeah after years I don't know how
it could look like and selfish about the
ages of meat work what would that in the
future ill if the Socialist Party
interline the 80s have done different
integration policy I think I think I
think what we are seeing in the we have
been two years in 83 84 985 during which
first attempt to amend to revise the
national envelope equation of them the
discourse about the the French society
as analytical study I've have been used
and from two years it has been said
French is a vertical Society so you know
somewhere to stay they got signal
generation the lead moguls so now they
start out the routine huge presentation
to society has to change and what
happened so the master bearers of the
civil rights movement in 83 84 and then
certainly national forms of the right
screen as we has better leverage in 84
so at the same time that they are the
civil rights movement there is a huge
that a nice reaction which is where fat
is not the way
which is going or so the case he says
few months when we're clear statement
that everyone will say that France is
that to this the web uniform you you
should be fine the way you find it when
you came in so don't touch it which is
exactly in the expedition restaurant
which is too much change so i think the
consequence of the National Front in the
eighties has been to free spool in bed
about how to reverse the representation
of French society and we have now 20
years ago after that still shredding the
same problem to try to well recognized
by that into type of society and a
specific incident when you define
national identity which is now following
the way our respondents is testifying of
their experience
but first I just wanted to thank you for
a really interesting and informative
presentation um I'm particularly
interested in the categories that we
construct and so I was very interested
in your decision to group your findings
along these these racial groupings
effectively and so I wanted to ask you
was that a subject of contention among
your team of researchers also to what
extent has that raised objections among
you know communities and France to which
you present this work and then also I
think that there's a curious asymmetry
in the categories that you use because
you use blacks i'm assuming throughout
and french for people of african descent
but you don't talk about whites instead
you talk about europeans and i'm
interested to know why why you've got
that asymmetry in your in your labeling
is very impressed by this have you
interviewed any of these people you
interviewed where they hit tube you'd
also according to socio-economic
differences if they were bourgeoisie
work in class this sort of thing also
among French people would you just refer
to the nativist the concept of francis
FFA and all of this there's big conflict
obviously with us the crack theory of
practice today among French people would
you say it varies among I could say what
among social classes who would be more
prejudiced would be working class people
upper class people before what was he or
something like that I think there would
be their differences
um it's interesting to see the two sides
and how they relate to each other and
there's this massive quandary study
others that I sort of have a really
small qualitative study and I was
interested more diversity within that
pockets that he you know I identity and
ethnic at that intensity really sad ones
while younger and most of the people who
you who you permission to use were you
know in their 27 verse 20 or 30 I'm
interested in people are older for that
amount of the life course
sort of ideas of the sounds of that
identity and then a second sort of short
questions sort of piggyback some of your
questions is that one slide which look
that description threaded people are
asked in their french and it seemed to
be steady but for blacks couldn't there
be a second at second interpretation of
that by five sanguine people actually a
lot of more insular you know immigrant
communities into you know more diverse
communities and so they actually are
asked often about their you know about
the role
that the marriage of two conflicting
so my question relates
not in terms of
french but in
generation 2 terms
they received their
terms of
cotton candy eight ways in which
can you be more specific about what
needs to change and you like I know it's
not what you're here to do but it's not
goes used to have a test for a little
bit possible to do this what we need to
change the education system in some
in order to add a more accepting
concepts it
kind of
sans fiction because everything
actually my question relates you
mentioned the fact that maybe more
inclusion of immigration story on your
history so into the national history
will help and that question is how
efficient with that be
we
some answers
you
so for the categorization and it's a 20
page as a very other process and it's
not stable so beginning the choice to
qualify the category is still under
discussion and me it was the damn to see
how significant findings we have when we
reconstruct categories not using what
about my problem that when we leave this
paper in the US that I just seen we have
almost 10 different countries for which
group of conspirators so divided by two
generation nexxt 20 so every time that
you are they really are 20 information
as soon as I do you use that we don't
even think about it but usually the US
yet for me which make it very simple to
get the differences and of course it's a
very schematic and has to be change
but in our case we come from the city
agency which is a very important one
because of course being English that is
only story and you gotta motivate status
and the government of Spain even though
you may need to see you exactly the same
way by natural predation and what is
tried by because I'm used use a true fan
of describing minions with a very
specific story of my wish should be it's
a very important part but what I
adversely is having word on this huge
data set the findings are straight very
very strikingly put together portuguese
italian
and Spanish regardless of the specific
east or to the earth and producer
receive apartment and we receive a
button for all society and somehow was
caribbean's good I'm not expecting to be
close to the South Africa and some has
been multiple that Enzo so after some
time you are finding these are very
recruiting findings just feel that since
it's something else to be meant by that
so that was mine so then okay say you're
bein done and white it is an important
thing it's because it's really what
bridge them is that they come from
Europe and the evening would be great
with the metra professional would say
white but in this case they are
separately or they are the major
provisions of our the analysis of most
this rather whether we should be white
category
food will be problematic as black as my
experience that it's already I really
good thing when I give paper is France
about raisin 76 right I talk about
blacks and most of the question and I
talked about White's at work using white
as a terminology what's the occasion of
the people in the other geez what you
want nobody asked important work that
goes without saying there is government
standing even though you don't have the
gallery I mean you don't tell you don't
try to see which beyond gay when it come
to white because we're going to identify
more immediate insist perimetry white
and always been very monkey and reaction
is on the white can read through causing
them savages and so it's saying that I
can't do the term use the nothingness in
France it's not an easy way to do to
graduate so what anyway and I'm not sure
that this community use extensively
naturally
is seven question about the social class
dimension which is a very important i
will start all the personalities
presentation with all the finding that
we have all the events are always try to
control that social class and education
which is very important very important
language when in terms of discrimination
look at work this is one of my very
surprised as well that an interview that
the original was expecting the most
significant part of the education of acs
that the high level of CSS and the high
level of education are mods community
against computers so you would expect
that is inside it's a working class
issue which is your goal to see as black
when your boy doesn't mess when you
climb the social ladder in fact it seems
that's what the identity because the
energy doesn't change our glow of the
social class but it's not if you
definitely when it comes from the
identity most of the rain is gone we
don't find significant active social
plans on this on this question we have
significant one which nearly those who
do have a university degree to d5
that modeling is creating against than
the others and if we shift or less
subjective indicator which is how many
situations of discrimination of
maintenance crew which is not as
depression air using the world's
creation it's a descriptive Lee in
education on labor market which is a
view in which use of promotion it's not
safe yes and all this question which is
a very descriptive in exactly similar to
those who are highly beginning are more
situational screen models but saying
that when you try to break the Bassett
II who face discrimination look more
than when you are remaining but the
position expected to be below so linear
progression is but you're not excluded
against because you don't get out of
your place ok just at the following
one's there
so I think it's not fun I remember
actually last year when someone said
mentioned the fact that you know what to
cross go to the US I think it's also to
even go a little bit further is to say
that there's a dozen difficulty to
acknowledge that your why and that it's
it's in a normative category and that
requires the majority and your position
of soft power I think there's a
difficult management of this that is
early i'm playing evolving the question
of age and their change over the course
of a flight it's a 10 interesting
question that actually would like to
dip a little bit but my my impression
with the with the interviews with that
closer to go to the expense of school
that the normative discourse about
French citizenship has been Civic as
it's an important part of the teaching
it's taught in civic construction as
part of the history in geography classes
from in secondary school in high school
so it depends of course
the way was introduced by the
professor's but it's an important part
of what is talk about what it is to be
French and I think the closer that they
are from this teaching their more they
articulate this understand of freshness
of civic and yeah a little bit it's
little tentative here because you could
think that when you still brought up
your family you're more identifying with
countries of your parents origin but I
thought it was more this idea that
French and SS as a civic sense that was
expressed and it's a little bit more
when people are more on their late 30s
and have been in contact with the
context of work and being assigned to
their origin in different circumstances
that may be there articulate a little
bit more this sort of ethnic description
so because of the discrimination
experience that we're talking about
his school is not often identified as a
place of discrimination whereas other
experience in life are more about it
plays a role in the way they declare a
sense of freshness so I think that's a
generational chance but this would need
to be further developed as a question on
corner history itself it's the way to go
since it's not introduced yet it's hard
to know but yeah I've been thinking
about this recently because they
introduced in mediation history in the
history program in secondary school so
now it's going to be a chapter that is
going to be taught and it's been a
debate and it's been a strong a strong
chance that a lot of people have been
asking for but it's true that we don't
know if that would really change
people's perception also depends on how
it's going to be taught for that
remember of it so this is something you
can ask for as for I really annoying
women's in fact will be it's divisible
eyes especially since I know like some
expensive in John in the US about that
so the teaching of black history that
decrease Kristin's getting of racism
it's not something to take for granted
so but what we can say that we we need
to have more I start working on called
answering friends in any case so and
that should be it should be
play
the questions the questions that you ask
were people being into the world do you
feel French or something along that line
if people were first generation second
generation immigrants another whether
they really interpreted that question is
being do I feel like I have the right to
be inference you know whether the
whether they turned the question and
something else in their heads before
answering based on their own immigration
history
version history of their parent there
was not that
there was what is confidential yet it's
complicated to say to tell exactly how
the interpretation wet and that's one
preliminary survey that you ask equation
you have a sector or the publication one
idea of the application to the question
is received by
in person we were made in different
meanings to that so we try to reduce
radiation be nice but still
it's only sure that the question which
rules will you pay French has been
really student same way
due to defy that as we have seen the
national identity is in debate for a
long time now friends I do think there
is not so much of the committee meeting
it's really about training time on it so
I would expect that they do receive the
meaning of killing French very far away
each other but maybe media could be
somebody and although the questions
could be double meaning
yeah but i had to quickly young
for folks who are excellent questions
were there any with any representations
of many Arabs or air French books or
black men folks because I just wonder
how maybe the questions the answers
might have been different one and then I
guess the other question is would have
so does that come up was I this is
computable I get a sense this generally
more like a cheapy and in France and in
its more common for you know whites to
flags and vice versa and have Fred like
intimate friends of a different race and
so it just seemed very strange to me
that if this is even a problem that most
seem that that was more the case they in
here it's very important point you made
it before got the vegetarians made by
the
20 ins and I've been perceived from
society which seem to be less
rationalizing this divided Russia life
than the u.s. at the same time which was
true one complicated story on the
services that you experience of ER jazz
man mother's work came african-american
getting the interwar period that they
went underground workers so they were
outliers in all respects and then we are
deriving actually in which blacks
wherever to lead exactly which is exotic
population we were external external to
the French society but he is clearly
greens so it seemed that it was not
matching the representation of the
princess and so they were somehow up how
does I will not take that as as as as
well as
information on the degree of racial with
other person is at the same time can I
say something
if they were also musical performers
that's not the same as the accountant
the teacher the doctor a musical
performer or a dancers already they give
spectacles and people applaud but but
you don't necessarily take a moment you
know that's that's also an attempt on
the result is to equally to account on
the little troops that we're friends in
post-world war instead sometimes we're
well complete will not only for me to a
relation because following the woman
from front around the Korean troops
where that they getting married in press
enter the charger prevent that Ramudu
one artist in ecstasy and time I see the
meaning of it I donation anyway why not
straight hello against mix mileage and
this time but for social social
perception we are not only open to so it
comes with my cell phone in the findings
that they're from survey that I am duly
impressed by the fact that we find
consistent finding that show that there
is a rush Holt segregation in a housing
enables racial segregation on the labor
market so there is a showmance that
shaping labor market but not and the
intimate relation the level of these
pilots are so insane that there is two
different societies one society is
organizing access to pour resources and
position social position in this case
there is strictly racial lines market
only advertise both embassy and by when
it connects the when it comes to the car
interaction dude by that there has been
this historical institutionalized
boundary between races or boots I think
it's easier to be to be in a more
intimate call me with most intimate one
which is baiting this holy
also in everyday life so it seemed that
the interaction on dividend is possible
and who's going to be marriage we're
having the structure of science society
is time I think that's that's what you
should understand on your homework you
guys are conceptual for that that's a
very positive because we are the
velocity infusion from the future and
other way it's something to say to a
cuisine and one of the other changes are
coming from there for the bottom the
motor group society is creating and that
so far as possible still to add access
well into society and more concern not
at the fact that there is determination
I'm open about the fact that there is
not an equivalent access the fact that
you got gatekeepers who are in nine
supermarkets most of the servers and
they prevent young kids of blacks
perhaps I want to get here people they
just suspect that they gonna stick
something on the problems and so open
access society
to foreign place of society which is
consumption is that authorized and it's
called following Russia lights and i
think it's the most devastating boundary
which is created in the french was a
lung infection setting which is
channeling the use of the winters
rotational channeling we use of social
not with specific laws preventing people
to do in space but that everything
practices and it even down by jenny
poussin blacks perhaps we are simply
following the prejudices in circulation
in society so that's the more darker
position for the evolution of french the
second cell so just to conclude on the
inside of the thing somebody as began is
mounted by giving taking very firm
statement of the diversity and the need
to try to reduce discrimination
enhance diversity in France it's simply
as changes by filling and you know even
more that these schools has not been
followed by which a complete change in
policy is submitting active and interest
is making us being in a more
stigmatization directions or the reasons
of people in schools these skills and
more than that I think that'd be my only
that it's not real change in the school
system of the change in the organization
of society in a very concrete way it's
also a change in the more symbolic
damage which I shall be done and if you
compare with the Dutch society with the
move even can talk love well movies I
sorry about musicals with an
oppositional with disabilities don't
monitor down in the late 70s beginning
of the 80s even it was purely symbolic
and not really inviting access to
equality in the society it was at least
changing the representation also say
balanced its controversial today but has
been retained obvious it does not be
done France and we still as strong as
restless as much
perception of the definition of
precedence is still based on a very
narrow position of what does being
defined I just want to try to summarize
with the findings and I think this is
the poor of the image that has trying to
try to be down mid eighties I have paid
and still on good on the table today
understands what is it for ok that's an
other question are you directing your
work specifically towards the factory
any change in this area are you very
involved in this or is it mostly
difficult like awareness that there were
you know education if I see if I see my
social responsibility as a researcher is
to try to reduce still claps
and the nation's vampire this in one
strike two easier to move towards moment
ago society appealed but because i think
it creates warrants and what in France
credited today and what is way too
against study which is facing this kind
of issue of vision and it is story
that's why
you